Welcome to Linux for Web Developers.
I'm Mike Wills and
I'll be your instructor for this course.
Every time you visit a web application,
your browser is requesting a number of
files that are sitting on a server
somewhere out there on the Internet.
More often than not,
that server is running Linux.
Therefore, as you develop and get ready
to launch your own web applications,
it's critical that you understand
how these servers work and
how to get your web application up and
running on one.
In this course you'll do just that.
You'll start with a quick
introduction to Linux, and
you begin exploring
the Linux file system.
How are files organized,
where do they belong.
I'll then introduce you to a number
of Linux security concepts.
Managing users, how to understand
permission system, firewalls, and
package or software management.
Finally, you'll get a very
basic web application up and
running using the Apache web server,
and a postscript SQL database server.
Managing and configuring servers is one
of my favorite parts of this career.
There's something very powerful in
knowing that you've taken a server from
zero to hero, all on your own and are in
full control of it's capabilities.
I think you'll enjoy this experience,
and in the end, you'll be able to
truly share your web applications with
others while having the most intimate,
low level knowledge of how people
are actually receiving and
experiencing your application.